to Ed Davis here with me good morning
great to see you thanks for joining us
um so people want more higher taxes
um well I think not sure if everybody
does um what I'm really worried about is
the government are going to cut taxes
for large corporations and things like
bankers and banks will get the Lion's
Share of that they're refusing to put
taxes up which I do support on oil and
gas companies oil and gas companies
making huge profits tens of billions of
pounds and liberal Democrats believe
there should be a windfall tax on those
taxes should go up on those oil and gas
companies and use that money to fund the
support for struggling families and for
small businesses the moment that
governments help for for people is
coming out of borrowing and that's quite
dangerous and risky there's a danger
that will put up interest rates even
more and so struggling families will be
hit by high energy prices higher food
prices and higher mortgage rates that is
a real worry for people higher energy
prices I thought they were going to be
capped well I wish they were there were
Democrats called for a energy price cap
to be frozen early summer the
governments are doing something but
they're actually allowing NG bills to go
up by another 500 pounds in October so
they went up by 700 pounds in April
they're going up by another 500 pounds
that's not a freeze that's an increase
and maybe 500 pounds isn't a lot for
conservative MPS but for their
constituents it's a huge amount of money
but they are then going to freeze bills
aren't they for two years which handily
Falls almost to when the next election
might be some might say they were
particularly being skeptical but you
know they are doing something and it's
going to cost a lot of money well
they're not doing enough for struggling
families because they're allowing energy
bills to go up by another 500 pounds and
one of the reasons they're not able to
do enough because they're not taking the
decision to tax the oil and gas
companies on their uh tens of billions
of pounds of unexpected profit so I
think the government don't have a good
plan they're economic plan seems
non-existent it seems to be right about
the economy that's what they're trying
to do that's what's been explained to us
well there's no plan for that is a lot
of ideology a lot of rhetoric but not a
serious plan to help stronger families
and businesses you know you're talking
to the gentleman from the hospitality
sector the government have failed the
hospital Hospitality sector and their
current plan uh to help businesses on
energy bills doesn't go far enough it's
only for six months you know businesses
will be reviewed after six months not
just six months they're going to look at
it again but if you're a business
employing people wanting to investment
you need a degree of certainty and
stability and the government aren't
providing that one of the key things you
need in in a real economic plan which
liberal Democrats are putting forward is
a long-term approach and frankly
something that's going to last for a few
months is not sufficient for businesses
who are trying to employ people
um it looks as though According to some
the recession has been fended off so I
mean we have to give this trust credit
for that don't we I don't think this
trust gets any credit for it and or the
conservative party they have mismanaged
our economy
um they are actually threatening the
future by having such a high level of of
borrowing to fund tax cuts for large
companies and for and for the the banks
that means they're threatening the
stability of our economy and interest
rates will go up far higher as a result
of that Reckless approach on borrowing
she has said I mean I'm just looking at
quotes from this trust you just say that
she's admitted that her text plans would
to start with disproportionately help
richer people and that's what she was
saying but she's doing that in order to
get the economy to grow surely that's a
good thing well um if it were true it
would be good but it's not true
um she's putting forward a very
ideological right-wing approach which
says that if you give lots of money to
the wealthiest it will trickle down to
everyone else that type of trickle-down
economics has been tried before and it's
failed Britain is a very honest Reagan
wouldn't agree with you on that I think
well I'm afraid America is a very
unequal society and Britain is a very
unequal society and it's partly because
conservatives have put forth this
proposal before and it's failed liberal
Democrats are saying we want a fairer
country and fairer taxes okay that's why
we've argued for this windfall tax on
the energy what else apart from that
because that's not enough well we
wouldn't proceed with this big
Corporation tax cut they're talking
about most of that money or a large slug
of that money goes to Banks and to to
multinational companies it doesn't
actually help many small businesses 1.4
million small businesses won't get any
help at all from that corporation tax
cut yet they're the ones who are
struggling the most and liberal
Democrats are saying you've got to look
after those small businesses those
they're small and medium-sized
Enterprise Enterprises who are really
the growth engine for our economy if you
want the economy to grow to grow liberal
Democrats would first of all back that
small business sector second we have a
serious plan on Energy prices and that
would include helping our industry to be
more efficient with energy because that
makes them more competitive
internationally we'd also insulate
people's homes and move faster to
Renewables because that's the cheapest
form of energy that's a real plan for
cutting prices for making our economy
more competitive and preparing ourselves
for the future the government they don't
really have a plan it's it's ideology
and it's been tried before and it's
failed yeah but insulating people's
homes is costing is going to cost quite
a lot of money how do we pay for that
well it would save money in the long
term but you'll have to pay for it to
start with well you do but there's that
sort of investment to say that
investment to make ourselves more
competitive is sensible our criticism
the government approach is they're
borrowing to fund tax cuts for the
better off and for Bankers that's not
sustainable our approach to the local
Democrat approach is sustainable it's
sustainable in terms of our environment
but in societal in terms of finances and
I am genuinely worried for our country K
you know I hope that by getting rid of
Boris Johnson and having a new start the
conservatives would bring the country
together would start having a sensible
economic plan for our country I'm afraid
uh the reverses happened I think this
looks even worse
um you had to or you chose to cancel
your party conference uh how difficult a
decision was that and she was quite easy
once we learned that uh the our late
Manchester's funeral was going to be on
the Monday of our conference we clearly
weren't going to go ahead uh in that in
that position and you know like the rest
of the country we are still really
feeling that sadness so the loss of of
our lay Queen and we didn't think that
Party politics uh uh just in that run up
to the funeral and the funeral itself
was the right thing to do so we decided
we would cancel our conference Mr cost
you a fortune
I think in the context of where our
country was we need to be come together
and liberal Democrats wanted to show we
were doing a little bit along with
millions of other people to bring our
country together to say goodbye to our
Queen and to to get behind our new king
and um yes it I'm not suggesting it
didn't cost anything it did but you know
sometimes things are more important than
that understood than money
um talk to me about the by-election
quickly Before I Let You Go Rosie Cooper
Labor's Rosie Cooper stepping down in
West Lancashire there will be a
by-election
um it's not a lib Dem stick really is it
I mean you've got 4.9 of the vote back
in 2019 are you going to step aside so
labor has a free run well first of all
can I pay tribute to Rosie Cooper I
think he's just he's been a great MP um
and uh I think she'll be missed by all
sides of the house and um well I'm sure
she's going on to other things and do do
lots of other contributions I think we
should acknowledge uh her contribution
so far I mean we look at every uh seat
when it comes up if you're not going by
election no of course not and we look at
everything uh seriously but what we
don't do is is waste money we don't go
into elections where we're not convinced
we can can win and spend huge amounts of
our resources there we tend to Target
our resources I think that's a rational
thing but you may step aside
um no we won't step aside we fight we
give the lecters always a choice you
will definitely of course we're the
candidate of course we'll have a
candidate I think that's the Democratic
thing to do I believe in giving people
uh Choice what I would say is that you
know we have shown that by-elections
over the last year that we can we we can
win and people didn't expect us to we
beat the conservatives in three uh seats
last time in the last last 12 months in
Tory Heartland in True Blue Book I'm
sure in North Shropshire where they held
it for 200 years absolutely they're in
East Devon so little Democrats are doing
well in these by-elections when when
people hear our case they come behind us
we're out of time it's always great to
see you thank you sir for joining us on
the program this morning